Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Esta es Mabel.
Mabel es un pulgón, un pequeño insecto
del orden de las cigarras, las chinches,
los ácaros.
Todos estos insectos perforan a sus presas
para succionar fluidos vitales.
Las presas de los pulgones
son las plantas.
Los pulgones buscan algo que
se encuentra dentro de la planta,
y que fluye por tubos de células
que van de extremo a extremo.
Son los tubos cribosos y juntos
forman el sistema de canalización
para el recurso más valioso
de una planta: la savia.
La savia se compone principalmente
de agua y azúcar.
Ciertas savias contienen tanta azúcar
por litro como una lata de refresco.
La fotosíntesis constantemente
produce azúcar.
Puedes pensarlo como una "bomba" química
que genera una presión increíblemente alta
-- hasta 9 veces la de un neumático --
en los tubos cribosos.
Para alimentarse, Mabel usa su estilete,
que es una aguja larga y flexible.
Lentamente, lo inserta en el tejido
entre las células de la planta,
hasta que perfora
uno de esos tubos cribosos.
Dado que la savia
está bajo tanta presión,
Mabel ni siquiera tiene que
succionar la savia de la planta.
Simplemente abre una válvula en su cabeza
y deja que la presión empuje la savia
a su sistema digestivo.
Volveremos a la excreción pero, por ahora,
notemos que las plantas
no quieren pinchazos ni sorbidos.
Por eso intentan defenderse.
Una defensa es la savia misma.
Para ver cómo funciona eso,
enganchemos hipotéticamente
el tracto digestivo de algún otro insecto
a un flujo constante de savia.
Cuando la savia toca las células del
insecto, su alto contenido de azúcar
hace que el agua de las células
salga por ósmosis...
de la misma forma que la sal hace
que salga el agua de una babosa.
Cuanta más savia pasa por el insecto,
más agua pierde.
Finalmente, se seca y muere.
El intestino de Mabel, sin embargo,
está lleno de una enzima llamada sacarasa
que toma dos moléculas de sacarosa
y las convierte en una molécula
de fructosa y una de...
esta tri-estructura de azúcar.
Mabel quema la fructosa
para obtener energía,
dejando la tri-estructura de azúcar.
¿Cómo la ayuda esto a Mabel?
Cuantas más moléculas de azúcar
se disuelven en la savia,
más agua puede salir
de las células de Mabel.
Al reducir la cantidad de moléculas
de azúcar en la savia,
Mabel reduce su capacidad de
succionar agua de sus células.
Savia neutralizada.
Eso significa que Mabel puede alimentarse
durante días, obteniendo toda la energía
que necesita para reproducirse.
Algunas especies de pulgones
tienen un ciclo de vida increíble.
Por ejemplo, el pulgón verde del durazno.
Durante el otoño, machos y hembras
se aparean, y las hembras ponen huevos.
En primavera, al eclosionar los huevos,
las ninfas que emergen son hembras.
Cuando esas hembras alcanzan
la madurez, no ponen huevos.
En cambio, se clonan directamente
para producir descendencia.
Entonces, estos áfidos hembra tienen
dos generaciones de clones bebés
en gestación dentro de sí
al mismo tiempo.
Los científicos lo denominan
desarrollo telescópico.
Eso significa que los pulgones pueden
producir descendencia más rápidamente.
Puede haber 20 generaciones
en una sola temporada,
y eso implica muchas heces de pulgón.
Mabel puede producir heces
equivalentes a su peso cada dos horas.
Esto la convierte en la criatura
que produce más heces en el planeta.
Algunas poblaciones de áfidos
pueden producir
cientos de kilos de heces por hectárea.
Las heces del pulgón
no se parecen a las humanas.
Químicamente, no es tan diferente
de la savia;
es un líquido incoloro
claro, dulce y almibarado
Puede que lo conozcan
por varios nombres: melazo.
A otras especies les encanta el melazo.
A algunas especies de hormigas
les gusta tanto que
actúan como "pastoras" y defienden
colonias enteras de pulgones.
A cambio, las hormigas obtienen
un suministro constante de dulce melazo,
que pueden beber directamente
de las colillas de los pulgones.
¡Hasta el fondo!
A los humanos nos encanta
el melazo, también.
Varias tribus nativas americanas
solían cosecharlo de cañas altas
para hacer tortas.
Y algunas especies de abejas
hacen miel con el melazo,
que luego los humanos
cosechamos y comemos.
Entonces, las plantas hacen la savia,
los pulgones la comen y la expulsan,
las abejas las regurgitan,
los humanos las cosechamos
y disolvemos en una taza de té Earl Grey.